[Music]
if you beat Amanda Nunez in July UFC has
hinted that you might go up against
Ronda Rousey you've lost to her twice
how would you feel about that fight well
right now I'm trying to really stay
focused on Amanda and I know everyone's
so excited for that Rousey fight I hope
that's something that happens but I
don't want to overlook Amanda because if
I don't beat Amanda there is no you know
there's no next granted I go out there
and do that you know I feel like I'm in
a really good spot on the top of the
world and I feel crazy possessive over
that thing right that's my baby I'm
gonna protect it right so having that
now you feel like it would affect your
next fight with Ronda Rousey no matter
what's like the past is the past
I'm at the best point of my career and
she's out the worst so I think that I
bring a level of confidence and you know
I've been I've been defeated before but
I've come back stronger for it you know
and I question whether she will be able
to do the same you're not sure she's
gonna be coming back I'm not saying she
won't come back
I just don't know she'll come back the
same because she seems awfully pouty
about you know about the loss and it's
like you know we've all had losses you
know you either get up and get back on
the horse and and you know come back
stronger for it or you set out for over
a year right right I like that the
trash-talking has already started I like
yeah call it trash but it's just me
being honest all right I'm people seem
to hear how she responds watch yeah like
she's gonna call me watch me to defend
her title to be like I can't believe she
said that
watch Missha defend her title against
Amanda Nunez July 9th at UFC 200 on
pay-per-view thanks so much for being
here
[Applause]
you
you